Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled
pepper mix it or packed a pic picked up
pickles make me think of family fun
summer and feeling on a tickle novice
I don't need pickles very often so this
is gonna be this convenient venture
pickled egg I actually thought that
these only existed in cartoons I was
kind of like a bouncy ball very sour
this is salad yeah there's like a rotten
egg after kind of love it take a green
tomato oh it's not an olive is it what
is this also smells I don't like this
one it does explode it is the right
amount of vinegar in it so it's not
child hour it's good I'd rather have
tiny only ten more eggs until e-beam
yeah what does it mean gravy
Oh No how can something be so rubbery
and so crunchy at the same time it's
like pickles like little cousin or
something like that comes around
sometimes
he's hi Nicole denies coolest pickle
well you tolerate them yeah it's
endearing
my first question is how long he was
fish been dead I might like be the only
black person who's grew up eating purple
coloring in the world good hi yeah oh
yeah you hate that oh it's soft it's
also rubbery
my favorite thing so far actually
pickled watermelon what part of the
watermelon is this it's the watermelon
part
onca what Oh skin of a watermelon okay
why would you do that to a warm milk
there's a slide - it tastes like
something I'm had before oh it's sweeter
little pink that's so foul tasting a
hotdog dad about always actual pickles
yeah that's what I'm talking that's what
I'm talking cheers Cheers
oh yeah oh yeah it's a great classic
it's a pickle
Joanie's change anything tastes great we
should really just stick to pickling
cucumbers H I love pickles
they are delicious I also like sometimes
knishes I go to your house and I don't
do the dishes that's all I got